[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir nos amis notre petit nicolas et
notre petite impro neil sont ils sachent
ce soir au genre tout autre os et bien
des 100 voire nounours dont lepa fort
aux pas trop pourquoi tu ne les aime
plus bien sûr que je les joueurs mais
pas quand ils me font de plaques au
mieux reçois mon petit doigt me dit
qu'ils vont être très gentil avec toi
aujourd'hui
alors j veux mon le seul os
j'espère qu'il est plus fâcheux notre
nounou chez moi il est très gentil avec
lui parce qu'elle aime bien
je ne sais pas si je dois roues
[Musique]
des notes nounours tu sues et je te
prends même on sera sage et ça c'est
pour toi
de violentes muffler bref les rues on
que ce gentil ce qu'elles sont bons
merci le petit assieds toi écoute on a
après une jolie chanson pour toi je vous
écoute les gens font ils étaient d'un
interdit dans un beau palais de tokyo
la muraille était de farine le parquet
était de croquer la chambre à coucher de
crème et du lait
le lit de biscuits le rideau de nuit
elle l'épousé monsieur jal est coiffée
d'un pourquoi mais je plains son chapeau
de galène de son ami était de nouveau
culotte de nougat gillett chocolat pas
de calais
giuly et le miel
voici que l'on fait dans la poche
jalousé de mauvaise humeur envers celle
d'un coup de sa gauche le palais sucré
du bonheur pour le bâti donné à loisir
de les bombarder
oui oh que le joli vous êtes vraiment de
gentils petits enfants vous savez il ne
faut pas manger trop de sucreries
ce n'est pas bon c'est la noce y
apprenait à se cacher
toi voilà j'arrive que ce que son ferme
les yeux et coûter jusqu'à 3 voilà un
deux de trois une grosse us et vous les
petits à jamais qui démarre ne mangera t
elle enfant exemple lé là je tends te
fatigue pas nos sources la jette à la
lumière on une bonne nuit mon honneur ce
mode muet
mecheri bonne nuit et enfants
ah voici notre nounours
alors tu es content pas trop ce qu'ils
sont millions il manquera tout regarder
les belles violer ce qu'elles sont pour
et cette superbe seul et bien dit dont
ils ont été très gentil avec toi ce soir
nos petits amis
connue pas trop ma sucette je vous la
donne
là car moi aussi je montre le bon
exemple
je la mange rue de ben bravo nounours
c'est très bien je te félicite merci
patron n'oubliez pas de me le donner de
mon dieu te le promets
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents allez vite vous couchez
effet de pauvres
[Musique]